la reine Élisabeth 2 victime d'une
tentative d'assassinat le 25 décembre un
homme armé d'une arbalète c'est un
produit sur le territoire du château de
Windsor il a rapidement et arrêter plus
internet le tableau et d'anglais the sun
se procurer une vidéo de l'intrus
présumé le jeune homme de 19 ans il
déclare vouloir assassiné à Rennes pour
venger un massacre commis en 1919 par
les Britanniques contre des manifestants
en Inde ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'un individu entre à Windsor ou à
Buckingham en 2019 par exemple un homme
à frapper aux portes du palais de
Buckingham restons plusieurs minutes sur
les pelouse avant d'être arrêté en 2018
un sans domicile fixe à lui briser une
vitrine puis rester dormir près du
Palais mets la plus célèbre intrusion
dans le palais reste celle de Michael
Fagan en 1982 qui était parvenu jusqu'à
la chambre de la reine contrarié par la
perte de son emploi et son divorce
l'intrus avait parlé plusieurs minutes à
la reine qui se trouvait dans son lit
avant d'être interpellé